What is going on guys welcome to episode three of ict for dummies
We just did candlesticks and now we're on to market structure and now we're going to help you interpret these candles
So you can actually understand the trend of the market
So as you can see of two different types of market structure on the left side
You have the bullish market structure on the right side. You have the bearish market structure
What does bullish market structure look like?
Well, it starts with a low and then a high and then a higher low and then a higher high
And then a higher low and then higher high continue continue continue as for the bearish market structure
You're gonna have the opposite you're gonna have a high you're gonna have a low
You're gonna have a lower high and then a lower low a lower high and then a lower low
Okay, so now this is what it looks like on an actual candlestick chart
So we have a low then we have a high then we have that higher low then we have the higher high
Higher low higher high guys. It's gonna be like really simple
And I know you do not want to be learning this right now, but I promise you it is going to help you in the long run
Okay, I know we're gonna get into models later. We're gonna get into a fair value gaps, you know liquidity sweeps all that stuff
But you need to know the basics to incorporate everything that we're going to learn in the future
And then for the bearish structure, it's the same thing on the candlestick chart guys
So we have a high put in place then we have a low then we have a lower high
Then we have a lower low lower high lower low lower high lower low and this shows bearish market structure
And this shows a bearish trend in the market. Now we're going to show you some real-time examples
You can have a better understanding of this. Okay, so we're going to play this out in real time
You have your low right you have then your high that gets put in place your higher low
You have your higher high your higher low
Your higher low your higher high then you have a low and then we have our little liquidity sweep
We'll get into that later. Then your low gets put in place
Your higher low and then high. Okay, you got it
And although we are not trendline trading and that's not what we will be teaching you it is still incredibly important for you to understand
The foundational movement of price action and guys it's a little bit cringe
But the trend is your friend at the end of the day higher time frame is always going to hold higher power
So I oftentimes see a lot of people just fading the overall trend
We're all time eyes right now. Stop trying to catch the top and short this right?
We're clearly in bullish market structure
So catch those longs and you will get the best possible risk to reward
You're going to get the best entries and obviously we're going to get those entries using our models that we're going to teach later on
But this is again the foundation that is necessary here. All right guys little quiz time. Let's see if you can identify the trend here
Bearish
Why is it bearish now, let's do a little markout while patty dances for me
So as you can see here
We made the high the low the lower high the lower low
If you didn't mark this out correctly, you might want to reconsider trading and you might want to just i'm just kidding
And then your lower high exactly like this is not going to be perfect too guys
I want you to know also in a market. It's not going to look perfectly just like this how we draw it out, right?
It's most likely going to look something more like this, you know where we'll do something like this
Like this is the reality of how the market is actually going to be moving so spend some time on the charts identifying trends
Marking out your lows your highs your lower lows your higher highs guys
Also, if you want to looking at this on a line chart makes it also a lot easier
If you look at the low you have your high your high or low, right?
And you can identify trends simply using the line chart if you can't understand with candlesticks. Yeah, look how easy this is spot trends guys
bullish
bearish
Identify the trends for breakfast we got just to reiterate this like the trend is your friend
For example when you're swimming, right you want to be swimming with the current if you're in a little river, right?
You're swimming with the current. It's really easy. You're just swimming. You don't even have to put much effort into it
Versus if you're swimming against the current what is going to happen?
It's gonna be a lot harder to push through that right and it's you know, you're gonna hit stop. Oh my god hit stop loss, bro
That wasn't on purpose
You're probably gonna drown, okay
Of course if you're hyper fixating on the lower time frame right now
It doesn't take a big brain to realize that the lower time frame is currently in a bearish trend
But if you focus too much on the lower time frame and distract yourself from what's actually happening on the higher time frame
Which is clearly a bullish trend then that's where you'll most likely find yourself getting manipulated out of trades and stopped out
So in a scenario like this where we analyze that there is clearly bearish structure on the lower time frame
But there is bullish structure on the higher time frame
we want to wait for bullish structure to form on the lower time frame maybe something like
And we're gonna get a little bit complex here
but if we came down a little liquidity sweep and then started seeing some bullish structure form and we can catch some longs from
there so the whole point of
Ict concepts really is it allows you to understand the higher time frame narrative and then use the lower time frame to find
The most optimal entry points. Okay. So now we're going to get into the market structure
Drop roll
shift
Shift in the market. So a market structure shift indicates a change in trend
So it is shifting from either bullish structure to bearish structure or bearish structure to bullish structure
bullish structure
to bearish structure
Okay, and here on the left we have bullish market structure, right? We have our low we have our high
We have our higher low, right?
We just learned this when we get a shift in structure is when we break through
the last
higher
Low, okay
So once we break through this higher low that we have and we get a closure below this
This can indicate a change in trend and then we start seeing bearish structure form here, right?
We then have our lower high our lower low lower high lower low and domain expansion
Market structure shift and this market structure shift can then happen back again to the upside
How by closing above the previous lower high, right?
So a bullish market structure shift looks something like this where we close above the previous lower high
And then we keep trending upwards versus bearish market structure shift. We're closing below the recent higher low
All right. So now we're going to show you what a market structure shift looks like on the actual charts
Okay, you can see here. We're in bearish structure, right? I don't have to explain this. We just learned this and then
Once we get a closure above this recent swing high that we made this is a market structure shift
Okay
This is going to indicate that price is reversing and we are going to put in bullish structure
And it has to be a candle closure
Okay
I see a lot of times people getting faked out thinking market structure shifts can happen just when the candle you know goes over this
Wait for the candle to close. It has to be the body closing above. It cannot be a wick
Okay, if it's a wick that is not a market structure shift
It's not a true market structure shift and as we get deeper into concepts and a little more complex
You'll realize that the bodies and wicks make a huge difference as you can see here
The body failed to close below this last low ended up wicking this low. That's a liquidity sweep
But we'll get into that later. Now if you look at this price action, what does this look like bullish market structure, right?
We have a sequence of higher highs followed by higher lows with every swing
Now what happens we break through this low?
We get a bearish market structure shift and once we get a body closure below this low
You can see that the trend has now flipped to bearish and we get bearish market structure
All right guys now we're going to show you the importance of body closures in real time
Clearly here you can see that we have a bullish market structure, right?
Crisis trending upwards we get higher highs with every swing and higher lows and what happens now price starts coming down
You think it's going to break through that low?
But no, there's a zero body closure below this low you end up wicking this low and what happens price continues higher, right?
So this is a fake out. This is not an actual market structure shift
And this is why it is so important to understand that in order for a market structure shift to occur
You need a body closure. All right, and as you can see here, we are clearly in bearish market structure
So what would a bullish market structure shift look like in this scenario? Well, it will be a closure above the recent lower high
So if we play out price here
We do not get a closure above the recent high
This is not a market structure shift why because we did not have a body
So this is a fake market structure shift, right a true market structure shift needs a body closure
Okay, and then as you can see we continue with bearish structure
Okay
So in this example, we have bullish structure, right and you wait for now a body closing below this low
Is this a market structure shift guys?
No, it is not right. Is this a market structure shift?
We get a body closing below this recent swing low. This is a market structure shift
I hope you guys are seeing this start marking out on your charts. That's going to be your homework for today
Mark out your market structure shifts mark out trends
Try to identify a bearish trend versus a bullish trend and try to identify when the trend is changing
And then once we get this closure, we also create this bearish fair valley gap
We get a turtle soup at these highs then we get a crt
I'm just kidding once you guys get a little bit more advanced and know all these ict concepts
You'll be able to find something like this nice little low resistance liquidity resting down here
You're gonna have a sweep of this buy side liquidity up here
And then you're gonna come down tap into this fair valley gap after the market structure shift and get this beautiful
2022 model. All right guys now a quick little refresher before we let you go all the way to the left
Here you have the bearish structure right next to it. You have the bullish structure right next to this
We got the bullish market structure shift
We start with a downtrend in price and then we break through this high
Which creates a market structure shift and then we get an uptrend in price and then for the bearish side
We have a bearish market structure shift
Why we were first in bullish price action and then we get a closure below the recent higher low
Creating a bearish market structure shift. Please remember
It has to be with a body not a wick
Okay, as you can see here we were embarrassed structure and then we got a shark structure shift
Thank you guys so much for watching this. Sorry for the lack of uploads. It was thanksgiving break
I was spending time with the family so it was blake, but we are fucking back
And we'll be uploading two to three times a week. So stay tuned
We're gonna be doing fair valley gaps next and dropping tons of psychology in between there as well. So stay locked in
And this was
I ct for dummies episode three. We teach you how to make